welcome to the NCBI minute you should be
seeing a slide that shows some
introductory stuff about the webinar
today we're gonna be talking about smart
blasts our new rapid protein
identification tool with me in the room
right now is Tao Tao it was also from
blast help like I am as well he's going
to manage things and answer questions
and they come in through the question
pod Tom Madden the leaf blast developer
will probably be joining us at the end
so if you have any questions be sure to
enter them in the question pod and
that's listed on this slide here we're
recording this webinar it's going to be
available on our YouTube channel and the
webinars playlist and if there are any
answers any questions that are you know
substantive and the things that
everybody would be interested in and
we'll have those available on the
material section that's gonna be on our
FTP site and it's going to be a link to
our webinars page and materials and
slides and everything for this
particular talk or up on our FTP site
and you can link to them using that
compressed URL that's listed on this
slide so the tool that I'm going to
introduce today is smart blast it's
designed to rapidly provide a name to an
unknown protein as well as to provide
some overall taxing on the context and
sequence length context for the close
matches to the most similar proteins in
the database we'll talk more about that
and then one thing I want to mention
about smart blast and I'll mention it
again at the end is that it's an
experimental service you've got a new
program at NCBI called PubMed labs or
we're putting some services out there
early in their development so that we
can get some feedback from people about
you know how useful they are or how they
would like to see them different than
the way they are right now so I would
think of it as a preliminary tool and
Tom Madden has just arrived so if you
have any questions for Tom he's here
before we dive into more class a little
bit I want to set some motivation for it
one of the questions that David Lipman
has asked and he's our director is what
are people doing with blast and so if we
look at what's going on with our protein
blast service
we've got about 50,000 or so blast P
searches a day and if we look at what
people are searching with most of the
queries the sequences they search with
have very many similar sequences in the
database in fact about 40% of the
queries have exact
matches in the database and if we look
at what people are doing just based on
where they look on the blast results
pages most of them are only looking at
the top five matches so that certainly
suggests a particular use case for
blasts and it's one that blast is a
little bit too much for the job if you
want to think about it that way in the
use case is simply to quickly identify
or assign a name to a query sequence
basically a full blast we search is not
necessary in fact it's kind of
inefficient if that's what you're trying
to do so that's sort of the motivation
for the SmartGlass tool that I'm going
to talk about right now
so smart blast is particularly good at
finding those close matches and giving
you some context for them and that's the
URL it's linked directly to the blast
homepage it's also available when you
run a blastp search you might see that
as a link as an option for you to try so
it has a couple of things going on what
is this rapid search for close matches
and it does that in two ways it does a
blastp search against the small what I'm
going to call a landmark database of
reference species proteomes
you get two matches back from that I'll
come back to that in just a minute and
the other one is a search against NR
that a fall protein database but it uses
a different algorithm it uses a rapid
algorithm a k-mer algorithm which is an
alignment free approach that lets you
search in are very quickly and generates
hits to the most similar sequences and
then make the alignments we use blastp
applies to sequences to do those it also
incorporates with the five matches that
you're going to get back a multiple
alignment that incorporates your query
sequence and from that we generate the
smart blast graphical display you're
going to see a protein tree that's going
to give you some taxonomic context
there's a graphical display that shows
you the full length relationships among
the query and it's close and the close
matches to the query this is a slide
that I stole from Tom Madden from his
talk about smart blast I'm basically
that's a procedure that I just talked
about we run that fast gamer search we
run the blastp search against the 27
proteomes then we use cobalt to generate
the smart class display one thing to
notice on this slide is the notice of
difference in the sizes of the two
databases we're searching in our has
about two point six times ten to the
tenth residues the reference specie
protium database is about a hundred
times smaller than that that's why we
can use a blastp search there and still
do it fairly quickly um this is a slide
that shows also stolen from Tom Madden
but it's nice tree view of the organisms
whose proteomes are in this model
organism database well we've got a
pretty broad taxonomic spread it's
certainly not comprehensive but it does
hit sort of the most important of the
most popular organisms that are in our
databases and for all of these we use
the proteomics for the annotations that
are present on the best assembly of that
organisms genome that we have so this is
the the heart of the SmartGlass display
and this is a search that I did with a
translation of an open reading frame
from the lychee nut transcriptome and so
I can quickly take that protein sequence
that's basically a novel protein
sequence as far as the NCBI databases
are concerned we don't have that protein
I generated it and I can quickly find a
name for it that's probably a DNA
mismatch repair protein and then with
the name that I would want to take that
from where the green matches there those
are the reference or the landmark
genomes so the arab adoptions genome
would be the one that would probably
want to grab with a name this is the
mlh1 homolog in this plant we have a
bunch of other plants it set some
taxonomic context it gives me the
conserved domains you can see the things
that I would expect for the mlh1 protein
and the graphical overview shows me the
full length relationships among those
proteins so there's the name where we
could get from the reference database
and serve the main results and the
multiple alignment is used to generate
these graphical views that you see we
also have the traditional style blast
report below it so you can see it for
the three hits from in our and the two
hits from their landmark database and
you also have additional hits that we've
collected and saved from the landmark I
mean in our database okay and so I'm
just going to do one example and this is
supposed to be a short webinar so let's
keep it that way I'm going to go now to
a web browser and so there's the blast
page and you'll see that there's a link
there to smart blast and if you follow
that materials link you can do this
later
yourself there's a little text file
there that has some stuff in it
there's more stuff here than we're gonna
do for this short webinar but what I did
is I did exactly the same kind of thing
that I did with that lychee nut
transcriptome this is a sequence from a
striped bass transcriptome that I
generated by finding an open reading
frame on one of the assembled RNA
sequences and so in essence this is a
unknown protein it's from a vertebrate
so that means that it's likely going to
have lots of very close matches in me in
our database and if I'm really just one
I have a good name for this breaking I
have a really good chance of finding a
homologous a human or zebrafish that
would tell me something about what this
protein is and I also might be able to
find some other fish species that have
this homolog in there so I'm just going
to go ahead and do this as a live search
and I'm going to grab the whole sequence
except for the asterisk there that
represents the stop codon so we're going
to copy that and I'm going to go to the
blast homepage and I'm going to just
click on smart blast here to get to it
and I can just put my protein sequence
in there and now what I want you to see
in one of the real beauty parts of this
is how quickly this happens so this is
practically instantaneous and so right
away
I've got a result that tells me pretty
much what I need to know that this is if
I look at my graphical view over here
I've basically got the whole thing and
it happens to be a protein that I would
expect to find in any vertebrate genome
this is a cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator I can grab the
name for from the zebrafish or the human
protein that's shown there and it's also
kind of cool because it shows me some
taxonomic context for the fish species
I'm working with and in fact
gratifyingly this works out just right
because the closest protein in that tree
on the left-hand side is from a fish in
the same family this is a european
seabass these are fish in a different
family but they're all four of them are
in the same group of fishes zebra fishes
and a different group of fishes and you
can see that it's more distantly related
protein
I can generate the full multiple
alignment by clicking here that opens a
new tab so here are the five sequences
including my query which is at the top
there and this is the cobalt display
which many of you may be familiar with I
can change the way this looks myself I
like to see the expanded view and I like
to change this to identity this gives me
some so I can see what the differences
are among these different proteins and
this is a full-blown multiple sequence
alignment so you've got the full length
appreciation of how these proteins are
related to each other which is different
than what blastp gives you you can of
course generate cobalt from a blastp
search result this is a handy way to do
this that gives you a nice concise view
of everything and then down below I have
the five hits that I get two green ones
here which are actually the more
distantly related ones these are the
ones from the landmark database and the
three here are from those other fish
species that we saw in the tree above
and then these are additional blast hits
that we saved from both the landmark
database search and the camer search
against NR and of course you have the
traditional blast alignments down here
if you want to see them okay now last
thing I just want to mention before we
close is the smart blast is part of the
pubmed labs feature of NCBI so that this
is under rapid development and we want
to hear from you so if you click on this
please let us know what you think that
sends a feedback form to the development
thing and they can take your suggestions
and into consideration for making this
more useful to you and I just have a
couple of slides one slide left actually
so let me go back to the slide show
just to mention PubMed Labs in general
if you want to know more about this as I
said this is these are going to be
experimental services where we're
requesting input early in the
development cycle and we do have a blog
many of you may know about that blog
it's called NCBI insights and so there
is a nice article there about PubMed
Labs and also an article there about
smart plastic
find useful and so I'm gonna stop
talking now and let's see if there are
any questions that people have written
in and I'll leave it I'll leave the
webinar open for a few minutes in case
anybody wants to what's the ask question
I see one question in here that I think
I can answer so well Lana says what if
the query sequence is much shorter
I guess he means them database sequences
what you basically see is in the
graphical view you're still in a try to
align the whole thing with you're going
to see that it doesn't align the parts
of the other proteins that don't align
with the query will be shown so you're
basically are going to have a gap at the
end and cow says to tell you that
insulin works fine I'm not sure what you
mean yeah as a short query remember also
that smartblast is not incredibly
sensitive so if you start using really
short sequences they're not going to
give you a lot of results I also wanted
to point out there's a if you want to
mess around with some of the examples
that I have in there it's not uncommon
for you to put a sequence in smartblast
and get nothing back because remember
that smart blast is designed to find
very similar sequences there are plenty
of sequences out there in the universe
that have nothing similar in the NCBI
databases for those kinds of sequences a
lot of times things from metagenomes are
gonna have to do a full-blown blastp
search so term wouldn't we say that he
if anybody has any specific requests
about smart blasts they should go ahead
and use the feedback when you use a
feedback link if there's something that
you want to request about smart blast
please use the feedback link and tell us
about it yeah so I have a question the
most distant hit that it can find it I
don't quite know how to answer that
Tom's gonna take a stab at this one okay
so as Peter was saying smart blast is
actually doing two different kinds of
searches one is the camer search which
is an alignment free algorithm and we
find that does pretty well down to about
70% or so and so that's gonna find the
very close matches and you know if you
go to run a blastp search you're gonna
get a lot of stuff that's about 70% the
other part is it's just a standard
blastp search and that's as sensitive as
any blastp search so searching the whole
event
or you can go down to about 70 percent
searching the 27 proteomes it's kind of
a standard blastp right and so those you
can you can see pretty distant things
there because it's quite it's quite
common that I observed that you can find
things where the only matches you get
are to the reference statements yeah so
that would be possible and I guess the
idea of the reference databases as or as
Peter calls that the landmark is it
gives you some landmarks of proteomes
that might be fairly distant from your
query so this is a question about it
would be nice if the color bars showed
some representation of similarity of the
query of the matches the histogram of
the represents the sliding window again
I think that that qualifies as a request
and write it up and send it to us and
we'll take a look at it so that way we
have a record of it and we can take a
look and see how feasible it is dude so
I think Wayne's questions legitimate so
Wayne this is a plant because Wayne is
actually one of us petite he wants an ID
to get an R ID and the answer is yes you
get an R ID but currently we don't have
any way for you to to save it yeah so
basically it's easier to rerun there is
an R ID around but it I'd say just go
ahead and rerun it and we might actually
just kind of change as Peter said this
is part of PubMed labs so things could
change pretty quickly and so we don't
want to make any commitment to how we
deal with the RIT right now searches are
so fast and the only thing you can do is
enter one query so I don't think there's
a whole lot of advantage to sending us
in our IDs do you have a question about
something if they have a question I yeah
I mean if you just send us what your
query was you know we can find out what
happened in about 10 seconds so yeah and
of course the question that someone just
asked is there a command line program
which of course I knew somebody was
gonna ask that and the answer is no not
right now I don't know that there any
plans to do that
uh no not right now right so it would be
very complicated to make it into a
standalone program so I think we're
going to go ahead and wrap it up thank
you all for coming and we'll you know we
got several questions here that might be
worth compiling so we'll go ahead and
put those in a document so I'm going to
go ahead and stop talking now thank you
all for coming
you